[Applause]
they have become known as the Tennessee
three three Democrats who loudly argued
for gun control in the state they faced
expulsion from the overwhelmingly
Republican legislature for allegedly
breaking rules in decorum two were
kicked out the two black lawmakers
vice president Kamala Harris made a
hurriedly arranged trip to the state to
show support from the Biden White House
for them and their arguments
says you don't silence the people you do
not stifle the people you don't turn off
their microphones when they are speaking
about the importance of life and Liberty
the punishment the two men see was
driven by racism it was a public and
political lynching it was an attempt to
humiliate us but in what they did was
really show for the world and humiliate
themselves that this is not a democracy
that this is you know a body that is is
so petty and so weak and so built on
white fragility on March 30th state
representatives Justin Jones and Justin
Pearson rallied with gun control
supporters inside the Tennessee house
but then the two took their protest onto
the chamber floor using a bullhorn to
chant no action no peace
one week later nearly all but one
Republican legislator voted to expel the
men while a white woman legislator who'd
stood with Jones and Pearson just held
on to her seat Democratic officials have
called the expulsions shameful to me
it's it's a horrific indictment on the
Tennessee GOP and they ought to be
ashamed of themselves and the fact that
they continue to keep their foot on the
accelerator when they knew the world was
watching really just shows what this
Republican party has has sunk to new
lows almost lost in the Uproar the
reason why the two Democrats and
hundreds of students teachers and
parents had been protesting a mass
shooting at a private religious school
on March 27 three adults and three
children were killed legislators say
ultimately gun control needs to be the
focus I'm asking folks to who are mad to
stay mad both men could be back in the
Tennessee house very soon they could be
appointed by their districts on an
interim basis and then they will lead
the fight for gun control
and to stop these kinds of expulsions
from happening again Alan Fisher Al
Jazeera